do you jude this is a pian good to meet
you see buddy we saw each other on a
plane yesterday and we're talking about
roods book and I'll just call you and
I'm pulling your route it's it's a it's
about to relate a story that would have
been really bad so welcome to the show
oh thank you forever why would the story
have been bad because it was a bad story
or because I don't slam somebody else I
used to work with so I'm not I'm not
doing do you do you want prep or no do
you only take prep for 30 days my gay
homies like a lot of fun that's how I
take it how much was that no no no I
[Laughter]
don't one of them I have AIDS the other
one won't so they'll just take it
everyday like a daily vitamin yeah but
not for 30 days you got to keep taking
if you don't want to get it like you got
to stay on it what the thing is AIDS
yeah discussing AIDS yeah how to avoid
it yeah how to not get AIDS they got
this pill called the prep pill oh
Truvada does the actual no there's other
things you can do besides taking a pill
to not get AIDS exactly but for doing
those things and taking the pill if
you're exposed you got to do it for 30
days and then you're then you're good I
just exposed myself and then I stopped
after the 30 days it's not a test run i
man yeah look bra went down on I went
down on a hooker and then I came home
and my mouth was bleeding and I was
freaked out and so I focus now you got
an open cut you know it's like and I
don't know this bra you know I mean like
so I just started I started I had mad
anxiety I called up my gay homie I was
like my AIDS homie and I'm like yo bro
like I'm kind of freaked out he said yo
get the prep and I want to grab that
[ __ ] and see what can it happen though
I didn't know if it would work if you
already had like I tested negative I
just got my test results back and every
time I get him it's a [ __ ] horrifying
experience I can't go through this
anymore so I started taking this this
pill and just to be saved and I have
done nothing in the last month that
would but I'm like taking it just in
case
i'm taking [ __ ] prep I don't care yes
[ __ ] I'm not gonna I don't want to
catch that [ __ ] you don't need to
but I might stop take care because I
know I know but I mean I'm like now that
I'm kind of monogamous with somebody I'm
like I probably won't need to take it
but right I just started taking it but
I've been constipated if anybody wants
the side effects
I haven't [ __ ] properly in a month
[ __ ] horrible like little tiny gluey
shits yo I'm looking at the I never saw
the ads for it it's like the best
looking [ __ ] gay dudes ever just just
barely and yeah it's a humiliating like
to have to see a friend that's the guy
yeah Truvada is the medication and prep
is like the slang for it yes I see yeah
it keeps you from getting it but there's
one you can take once you have it that
prevents you from passing it too but I
just got test results back and I'm good
I mean I can't believe I'm so [ __ ]
relieved how many eight squares have you
had Jude that was that was only like you
know that you're always when you when
you have a promiscuous lifestyle you're
always freaked out when you go to get
your your your test it's like getting
your credit score or your mother [ __ ]
hates tests and that [ __ ] freaks me out
but that doesn't need to be tested every
three months wow that was good about two
years for me on this last one and
believe me two years of me that's 50
years for most people the fact that I
didn't get tested for two years is crazy
it's crazy an AIDS test I don't think
I've ever had one so you still with the
girl yeah how long two years
yeah okay monogamous I'm perfectly fine
maybe weird if you were like influenced
by this radio show though and you went
home and started taking prep pills right
like what are you taking AIDS medication
for just cause just cuz I thought it'd
be good that's why I take propecia I
took it before I even started balding
like I don't yeah I've like I lost like
two hairs on like one side of my head
and then I immediately started taking it
and the hairs came back the two came
back yeah that's amazing yeah I caught
it early did you get them anywhere at
this propecia [ __ ] you I like I don't
want chest hair no no
my dicks fine and really yeah not at all
why is it rumored to kill a sex drive
have you heard that I mean like if
you're if you need to do it like five
times I mean it does a little like oh
I'm like a 1 1 or 2 and done like I can
in a night yeah I can't but that's what
I thought but I've told that to some
guys in my hall I don't know about that
pill [ __ ] more than that by the way
once or twice twice a night what some
once and I'm like I cured more than
enough yeah more than enough I stop
taking Cialis recently I had been taking
that like I have addicted to it without
at my dick was worthless like worthless
and I stopped in for like a month my
dick didn't budge I'm like a pig's tail
just kind of sat there and I [ __ ] my
dick finally started to balance out now
that I stopped taking it it's like your
body kind of adjusts and not taking it
but any of those dick pills can get very
psychologically addicting you start
getting used to it and physically you
get lazy because if you just take it
your dick is hard you don't have to be
turned on if I stopped taking you take
dick pills to assist with your miscues
lifestyle yeah I do oh you do you take
I'll take I get that I get cialis from
India
I get like Hindu cialis and just [ __ ]
oh you can get the viagra from India too
but I do it i pair it with drugs in I'm
always like you know you just you know
mixing medications certain drugs will
just kill your penis so it kills your
dick like tight sometimes sometimes GHB
if I do too much GHB but you can I mean
you murders it Oh No HP it's like um you
should be able to get it at GNC and it's
like for bodybuilders but they figured
out if you gave too much to people who
knock them out so it got put in a day
raped right category yeah yeah I like
you last time Jude was on when he did my
night show yeah I can him I come up with
like 11 o'clock at night and he had like
a 5-hour energy with him and he was just
like drinking out of a cap the whole
time I was like what are you doing like
in the middle of the segment he's like
HP is what I'm doing right now I was off
the clock in my brain
came out of a time machine I don't like
the 90s I'm going for a time like this
this nice smart white sweater his jeans
fit in well in their cuff he's got like
he would never guess that this guy does
drugs no a lot of them or has beaten
aids you know I feel like yo I feel like
if you're gonna be in Mike my little
cousins and stuff they they're like
hippies and they're like anarchists and
you can see them coming a mile away
right if you're gonna be against the
system look like the [ __ ] system
that's the way I like squinted at you
like you know you kind of look like
Jeffrey Dahmer and you're like kinda I
could look like Jeffrey Dahmer actually
dress up like Jeffrey Dahmer for
Halloween all right [ __ ] you do look
like yeah I I never I I'm looking I'm
like I felt like a little Joe Pantoliano
pair to the oh no how are you say his
name joy pants but no Dahmer is much
more reserved the guy from The Sopranos
yes kids out of the bar when did you
show on by the way come on yes Ron shade
45 1 4 to 7 on Monday through Friday
yeah all out show it's a very very
popular show because he's a Judas out of
his mind so it's perfect incredible
honest to me I love the fact that you
talk about what you do are you in a
relationship now or no I am been in 105
years bro it's hard I feel like I I
can't even have someone sleep over
because I'm afraid I'm a fart you know I
mean like I already know what I'm gonna
open up to people yeah like that's some
real intimate [ __ ] farting on a girl's
leg right no you're right should I do it
on her dick
to the trans world at all nah there was
one time where I thought that I thought
that I might have banged out a post-op
Filipino but it was like you mean she
wasn't Filipino before the operation
she's Mexican but no yeah I thought I
was she's like see our real broad
shoulders and fake titties when she was
riding me in like the [ __ ] felt weird
it did but I was just like we've gone
this far
like I can't unring this back so I think
if you're halfway through a meal you
like I just send it back you said you
felt one fake vagina right I did I know
weird yeah and it was a weird instinct
you have because it didn't feel like the
way a [ __ ] feel it just felt different
and I can't describe how it felt to
image like dryer or like dolphin [ __ ]
god that's a [ __ ] great description
exactly felt like we're like that's it
felt like a rubbery like not a dolphin
[ __ ] is an amazing way so funny when
you said that the last thing I expected
was somebody to be like yes exactly
it just sounds right but it feels weird
it felt weird and I don't know why but
again that's many many many years ago so
now they're probably even better at
doing that you were also struggling
because it felt weird cuz the genitals
were internal no no I was I was looking
for a vagina Oh oh yeah I was looking
for a vagina and that one was just not
did you see the sex robots that could
apparently kill you no is that right
they said that's the beginning of the
end me they said that don't get the sex
robots yet because I haven't worked all
the kinks out and hackers could hack
them and program them to kill you which
i think is the saddest death of 2500
hours in this thing bites your dick off
and choke you no no I had no friends or
no potential mates and their robot is
killing me yeah you're that most do to
yourself esteem when a [ __ ] sex robot
is strangling you yeah mili ating no I
can't go back in the house why my sex
robot is in there and trying to kill me
so I just gave her the house these look
realistic though and it's funny
the pocket [ __ ] like they feel good
but then when you're like cleaning them
out in the sink it's the most depressing
[ __ ] ever exactly keeping worshiping a
trinket really gave me a pocket [ __ ]
and he gave me uh I used to tour with
Andrew Dice Clay and dice years ago was
with happy face and club soda candy his
bodyguards goes we're gonna get you
we're gonna what would he call it silk
was the lubricant it's actually eros he
would call it silk yeah and the pig
[ __ ] I forget what he would call it he
had a weird name for it but he gave me
this pocket [ __ ] and I didn't know he
goes all the guys use him it's a ritual
I think he was just teasing me but it
was this black pocket [ __ ] and it was
it didn't look like a vagina
but you'd put it on your dick and it
felt weird and he goes did you use it
and I and I I think they were just
[ __ ] with me now is he always like
you know so happy to be torment dice
it's [ __ ] 1998 nine and seven and I
actually used the pocket [ __ ] when I
got home and it was great you liked it
yeah I forget can you remember the name
I can't remember what he called but he
called the lube silk and it's a silicone
base so amazing yeah it's called eros
eros or pure the other one is like water
so it gets sticky after a while yeah
like that relax no good eros just goes
bro you used it it's amazing yeah yeah I
had a problem with that for a minute now
I'm on coconut oil do you like that you
like like natural coconut oil yeah I
just get like I pop popcorn wood with
some okay so he was saying like once or
twice a night and I love that when
you're like once or twice a night you're
like looking around the room yeah but
like for you one nut bro you're a one
nut guy one nut and I'm done yeah I
could like I could hold for a long time
but like if I bust once I'm done even
the pills can't bring you back after
that I'm fetal position not even new
[ __ ] you [ __ ] can't bring you back nah
what is one new [ __ ] yes for me okay
we're all bro like wait I I just did I
just did SDR last night and somehow just
ER up sex drugs and rock right off
something yeah pocket okay gas network
and like they were having a kind
and somehow I end up getting my dick
sucked in the bathroom what yeah it's
crazy like I didn't sign I shall take it
you at the winner of the contest
barely I couldn't even get my dick hard
really it was very loud and pressure
sure a lot of pressure in his like we
wrote like I don't know man like I've
had a billion a billion [ __ ] it's
not like it's not like I'm seventeen
again I'm just stoked to put my dick in
a mouth you know like it takes more I
need a little finessing and the only get
me right the older you get the more you
realize like hey man I have things that
turn me on and this just doesn't work
like it used to when you're 17 you're
supposed to go like yeah mouth is enough
for my dick but now I'm like no there's
got to be something through it yeah
settle down with who you got cuz you
don't want to be some renegade otherwise
you become like a lady who's like no I
need a little mental stimulation I do I
need I need a whole lot god it's awful
what kind of mental stimuli what needs
to be said to you I don't anything that
just feels like wrong or worse that
we're doing tell me what I don't know I
can feel really dirty okay feel loving
it's just gotta be something it should
be but so it doesn't have to be naughty
no loving yeah like with the person I'm
seeing now like it's kind of it's really
nice we can be dirty too but you know
like what kind of stuff just whatever is
the one element I want to know like what
was the last moment share it with me
it was in Iceland uh-huh I'm done
betting being vague I don't remember the
last dirty thing was well what's like
one just making me do things otherwise
be inclined to do anyway thank you I
like that a lot though there was a man's
demand having your head held things like
that like I used to love when I would
look at I would look at like hustler on
watch the girls 69 here whatever like a
lesbian thing or I like to have the hand
on the back of the head just little
things do you like to do you like to
beat the man but except like gyms into
that like like talking about like your
exes and the other guys you [ __ ] and
stuff like that right Jim you're into
that just waving at dan Rather yeah
sometimes but with just girl not I don't
want to hear about our exes I'm like
that looks like her no I've liked other
girls I've had it just doesn't feel
humiliated like I'm okay with oh I like
this [ __ ] - yeah like tell me about your
acting a bigger dick he did uh-huh yes
right yeah right but that's probably
some young [ __ ] no that's probably
healthy yeah that's a healthier way to
be because you're enjoy your tactile
you're enjoying the moment for me the
mouth feels the same the [ __ ] feels but
I need more like alright how is this
wrong like for you it's just like hey I
love this girl nor having sex that's a
very healthy way to be you're better off
your dick won't work until you're 70
it's like to quit my early 20s for me
when I'm with a girl and she introduces
me to a dude I just figured she [ __ ]
him yeah that way I can just live with
it in I don't like I just figure she
[ __ ] everybody but she's with me and
and that's how I deal with being jealous
what convinces you what what convinces
you what convinces you dude that that
she actually likes you what will it take
to convince you like for me it's like a
lot of things like okay she [ __ ] this
guy she must have liked him better or
she [ __ ] that guy must have liked him
better what convinces you that yeah this
girl actually is with me and she's happy
forgive me I don't even think about that
my dick Center isn't that like isn't it
like isn't that like the cosine on the
loan my dick is in you you just look at
you like you're a different language
like what the [ __ ] are you saying right
now
you don't have that hang-up like you're
not like oh I'm not like mid-stroke this
is she into that I'm like I'm just I
just I'm just there you know like you
know you're like you want already kind
of or you know what I do you know what
sometimes I do I check them toes like
I'm banging it out I look if the toes
don't look like cerebral palsy I'm like
I'm not doing this right like it needs
to look like a little baby fists
pterodactyl er yeah that's how that's
how I check and see if she means it cuz
sometimes like you're straight I
remember one time I was like are you
even enjoying this and she was like kind
of and that one oh no yeah that hurts I
was bad for you
it didn't feel great right I had a girl
tell me that her boyfriend had again she
knew what I was into that her acted like
a bigger dick or guy she [ __ ] had a
bigger dick and I'm like I'm like well
mine is like kind of this close to it
and she wouldn't dull it's all I could
think of whenever admitted to me that
her ex-boyfriend add a bigger but you're
attached to your dick you know I mean
like that's the that's look like you're
attached to your dick she loves you
[ __ ] [ __ ] the size of dicks man she's
with you you start to think that way
after a while but this one girl had you
know the guy she was with before me had
a much bigger dick I started them
[ __ ] on video for sure she had a
video of them [ __ ] and she said she
would never show it to me I'm like I
want to see it turn me on so much and
she's like you're not gonna like it and
when she said that it made me so [ __ ]
crazy I'm like ooh it must have been so
dirty he got all horned up when she said
you're not gonna like a few girls that
have had that yeah but I needed it
because again I knew it existed and it
would be a [ __ ] it used to be I
always used to be so insecure about that
[ __ ] would drive me crazy and I would
sabotage and ruin relationships and then
I just learned to embrace
this great fear we have and I might just
make it work and then one day that punch
in the stomach all of a sudden became a
feeling I was like oh that's kind of
[ __ ] dirty because she is with you
now so I'm like she does like me now and
I know jerk off to her sex tapes with
other dudes I I wound up but it took
that [ __ ] demon off and then all of a
sudden the relationship worked but that
would have ruined things I wasn't crazy
you got a small dick or so no okay no
it's fine it's not gigantic but my think
it's fine I'm very happy with my dick
maryjean said it was good yeah I mean
she's seen it I've showed you know you
had sex with Mary Jane ever no I know
we've never fought I've never fooled
around literally I showed in my dick
soft she want I'm like a sauce because I
want to see it so I just like to put it
out and she looked at it and she cries
nice day Thanks yeah
Mary Jean is our is our on the street
reporter she's a star of adult film oh
yeah so she's like a doctor kind of
great Street interviews and she's quite
sexy
yes that's her right behind you yeah
yeah Mary jeans a [ __ ] trooper she's
awesome
and I've thought about having sex with
her you have oh yeah yeah yeah I guess
you have yeah yeah I've masturbated
quite a bit thinking about it is that
right yeah yet last time my last time
she was in gym confessed to us that
because she's got and hung out in his
place and no like you know getting the
jacuzzi but just hang out in the jacuzzi
and then she'll leave and then Jim just
masturbate furiously literally well not
before I hear the tink of the elevator
button I'm [ __ ] my face in the seat
where she were sitting and I'm gonna be
cool um she has her vagina does not feel
like a dolphin amazing fun have sex with
but it really and I'm again I'm not
saying she would do it I don't know if
she would do it but we've gotten to a
point where we're friends and it really
wouldn't want to ruin that it's not
about ruining it but I don't know if it
was like I like having her on the show I
love having her on the show and I like
hanging out with her we go to dinner
she's fun to hang out with and it's it's
like it if it changed the dynamic word
can wrecked it and it's a yeah there's
enough chicks out there for you to sleep
with to not like blow things up and I
don't know if she would do it anyway
I've never seen never said that she
would do it did she go crazy with you
because she said after she has sex with
guys she gets crazy and possessive nah I
guess I guess she didn't like having sex
with me that much no she gave two shits
I don't think she cared other women
that's a bad sign
like my friend yes and she did me so Bo
because we were supposed to do this like
science drug and [ __ ] and I was like
kind of science it's called to seee and
it makes like you could see sound and
like it feels like you're busted nuts
the whole [ __ ] time
Wow so I end up like way the hell out
like 40 minutes from my crib with her
and I eat that I in LA yeah and I eat
the science drug and I was like do not
eat anything and she had Cheesecake
Factory and like so I'm like super
[ __ ] up just wanting to bang and it
nothing's she it didn't kick in with her
and she was like don't touch me don't
touch me like I was like this hornball
in the corner like like Robin I never
felt more desperate in my life and then
finally it kicked in with her a hour
later and we got to have sex but was
your dick hard from this drug it was
hard from the viagra that I that's the
cocktail aim I was like I'll never do
that again with you no way through those
very selfish you're taking Viagra feet
or dick pill I don't think so yeah young
guy part of your bra guy on 15 bucks is
pop bro holler at me I love radio show
you got your books and you also you deal
viagra a big yeah you got a hustle man
you got a hustle you're right I say I
have a prescription for sale I love it
but again I haven't taken one in a while
trying to balance my [ __ ] days it
make you last longer yes it does perhaps
I should get over my Agra is really good
but viagra gives you a headache but it
works faster like viagra is in the pinch
like if you're in the elevator on the
way up and you're like oh no my dick is
valueless right now you pop a Viagra and
you wait you stall for a half hour and
your dick is pretty good but if you say
Alice takes like usually the next day
it's a weird drug
for me like a weird one uh and all of a
sudden you feel it in your back and the
old boy
my dick is phenomenal gets so hard that
it can hurt it can a little bit if
there's no threat to it like a heartbeat
in your dick yeah it's good yeah it
keeps you talking great you need more
more more time on you is that the
problem yeah I said I would like to add
some more time what time would what are
you working with right now
well here's the thing that there's been
no problems it's just like I would like
to have do move be a rock star yeah I
would like to feel very cool because
I've been in a relationship forever and
like I've told them like I'm seven
minutes start to finish
done yeah and that's like two or three
times a week seven minutes yeah that's
it yeah we're good killing it but guess
what like because of that like I don't
really - what you guys are doing at all
because I get excited every day it's the
same vagina every time and I get excited
about it every what do you get more and
more excited so much it is so excited I
get excited - what a healthy way to be
the to associate those two things as
[ __ ] is really amazing yeah it's
great it's so much easier x like what
you guys guy I think that's awesome good
I'll bet like because you've been doing
having drug sex for eight years you said
yeah longer than that yeah yes yeah yeah
so you probably are just like oh those
guys that's different
like I think Jim does that like that's
different I want the different thing
like that sounds great
but if you were in a relationship for a
while you'd probably be like remember
how much fun drug sex was I just finally
sick that would have drug sex with me
right that's the key right it was like
love+ drugs thanks that'd be [ __ ]
awesome that would love drugs sex the
love thing is uh I feel uh very loving
with this person so so yeah with her I
kind of feel it like no G will you say I
love you when you're having sex yeah Wow
in the middle of it mmm and it's Wow do
you talk dirty or no you know I'm dirty
talking yeah no that's the best way to
be it sounds like it's just it's like
I'll be embarrassed really I would feel
weird saying what my thing is I love her
too much you like this yeah I'm afraid
answer no I don't even know I'm not I
wouldn't know what to say when will you
say I love you in the middle of things
or as you're as you're getting closer we
just both say I love you when yeah Wow
that's stunning yeah anybody in a good
way like I would love to do that maybe I
will
I had a girl tell me she loved me this
actually was fun it was fun or did you
feel the same way to get freaked out I
felt loving towards her but she I knew
we weren't gonna date this is a while
ago wait you weren't dating her and she
just said she loved you or you were
[ __ ] yeah we had hooked up a bunch of
times and then she was like I love you
kind of yeah that's weird
I love you puppy okay that's no
different yeah now we understand yeah I
should like this weird domination thing
with this chick and I'll be like say you
love me she like I love you and I'm like
I love you turned her the [ __ ] on I
think but like it breaks the part
that'll break your brain after a while
that was like yeah that's hot hey
Atlanta having some problems down the
road I didn't love her but she like
being an object she like being used to
[ __ ] let's do something about that
mentality of just being used as a whole
a lot of people get off on that it's
just simple and based on animal she was
like a webcam girl so like all these
dudes just throwing all this money at
her dick riding her and I think you know
like I wasn't there to save her I wasn't
there to judge her she could do whatever
the hell she wants and didn't even love
her no no I was just like yeah we're
here [ __ ] and like that's just what
she needed so I gave it to her like it's
not it turned me on that it turned her
on because the other guys are probably
saying I love you I'll take care of you
that's what I'm doing this yeah let her
be like BB Buddhists let them do what
they're gonna [ __ ] do man
yeah I [ __ ] up with the web I used to
[ __ ] a web girl but I would always say
things when I was [ __ ] her like I'm
gonna rescue you
I'm gonna give you tokens and make you
feel better really respected yeah she
really did I studied to be a nurse yeah
follow your dreams
I'll be there for your relationship yeah
yeah I guess this is the difference from
where other guys was telling her and
that is a lot of times what it is cuz no
guy said that to her I don't love you
like that's a [ __ ] hot thing to say
yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] you and send you
home and you can go [ __ ] get pay by
them lames
she be like but I think if this girl
said that to me it would bother me like
I think the cuckolding stuff it's not
that I didn't love the other girls who I
did it with but just the dynamics of
this were a little bit different right
and I think if she said that to me I'd
be like were you in a relationship with
the other girls that you did it with
yeah yeah and some of them I wasn't I
was if I still loved it they're all you
know some of them I was very in love
with and some I had just dated and cared
about a lot look at you head over heels
yeah well yes heels at shoulders
actually so you know oh by the way bra
Judah's publish promoting a book so
you're really a funny dude man and your
radio show we were hoping to have you on
this challenge it's called hummingbird
and now where can they get it you are
rude underscore Jude on Twitter right
now sign copies I got a little bag right
there I will read it you are hilarious
rare rare bird books calm
yeah we're just got it like look man the
easiest ship for y'all cats cuz you know
probably half y'all hate me anyway and
[ __ ] alright who's the [ __ ] wigger
well by the winters [ __ ] book on
Amazon will one click and then you can
see yo you know I'm telling I'm telling
stories of people that don't really
write books you know right and by the
way when people say stuff like that when
they call guys wiggers whatever like to
me there's a if all I ask of a human
being is that they're consistent
regardless of who they're with and
you're a consistent guy dude is the same
guy on shade he's the same guy with us
right you are this is who you are as a
person this is how you this is not a
fake thing this is who you are there's
guys that will talk one way and there's
black guys that do it too they speak one
way with one group they speak in other
words another those guys are fake people
if you speak the same way with any group
you're with and you're a consistent
person that there's no shitty label
to that you just who you are this is who
you are as a guy and yeah but it breaks
people's brains it's like yo man this is
I just sound like where I'm from yeah I
just sound like where I'm from much like
everybody sounds like where they're from
yeah yeah that's when guys don't sound
like where they're from or when guys
were what like we've seen actors do it
where they come in and they sound one
way here and then they go on sway and
they sound another way and it's it's
it's just one thing I do that on 90 day
fiancé did you really know [ __ ] bad
this guy was like he had a Russian he
was the guy with the Russian mail-order
bride or whatever that was that working
out and Tifa her name is right now it's
not working
oh no and he went to his black friend to
get advice and like all of a sudden have
a lot of white friends that that like
act a lot different around Black Keys or
they'll just have a completely different
opinion and then if a black person says
something different they go like yeah
yeah exactly that's right it's like my
laugh changes around black guys I don't
like that
how do you sound like no but it's
insulting to the person you're talking
to course it is because it's like
literally like saying like you'll you'll
like you'll relate better if I and so
you know let's say that about us bridges
ridiculous stuff at home he's come out
the closet and suddenly there's they the
swishy is talking I'm like where did
this go when did you get so sassy broke
well that means the guy they were before
that was the put on that's where you're
seeing the real guy it's like they've
taken off the [ __ ] the costume and
that's probably who they really are
instead of becoming this whole oh my god
that like that's probably how they
always wanted to talk but they had to
toughen it up a little bit so you would
like them we were just talking about
people who do like fake accents around
other people and there's actually a clip
that I thought maybe I'd share with all
you guys if you guys want to hear this
actually a friend of mine yeah he got
around Ozzy Osbourne and my friend
started speaking in a British accent for
no reason no reason is he's obsessed
with Ozzy yeah well you know I think
this guy in fairness I think he's a good
guy I didn't think so I
so I think it's just PayPal he panicked
in a moment and uh yeah it happened
Ozzy Osbourne don't anthony take a seat
my friend
yeah Jimmy lost a lot away just go to
the gym just go on the gym and eating
better like Trainspotting I'll tell you
why that he put on an Irish axe I know
something it was and I wondered why that
I didn't realize it until afterwards
wouldn't boy and boy did Anthony realize
he was joking when he said Ozzy Osbourne
I did it because I I think I wonder why
it was more panic like my mouth was
closed like I just panicked because Ozzy
recognized me I joked around and said I
all I want is for Ozzy to remember me
once I always felt like he would never
know me and not only did he recognize me
but he realized I looked I lost weight I
was blown away by the fact that is my
favorite person in history him every
trip right hand but Ozzy's my favorite
pride person and the fact that he knew
I'd lost weight it was literally nothing
I had ever dreamed of it's awesome
but that freaked me out that's why I did
that panic here's what happened you
wanted to relate to Ozzy so badly that
you started talking like him no it was I
would admit if it was I would tell you
but it didn't feel like that it was just
a moment of panic because I haven't I've
interviewed him before it was more the
shock of him knowing me was was was I
forgot about that really bad yeah but
again that's humiliating and I have to
own it did you uh is hummingbird like is
it similar to hyena in the sense that
it's just like a collection of stories
they're kind of about your life it's not
one sort of no it's a bunch of stories
it's just it's just a it's like forty
some stories sex and drug stories a lot
a lot more drugs and a lot of a lot of
like pre puberty and like Pontiac
Michigan so would you have to go back
like you're like okay this crazy [ __ ] is
happening to me I got to start writing
about it you start writing and then
you're like wait there's like childhood
stories that I haven't written about the
first book was all like crazy sex and
[ __ ] and then like I was like what's
this next book gonna be and I was doing
I was doing ketamine on the couch
sure
I was like okay right also a great name
for a book right
ketamine on the couch and I'm like so
and I'm [ __ ] in a k-hole and I was
like I just I was like this book is
hummingbird and it's not gonna be hyena
and I got up and I wrote like while I
was high I wrote a piece about look I'm
Italian losing my auntie her dying and
then my new new my new new and up about
my Narnia new new become getting
addicted to gambling and then what's
Narnia new new who's who Nanni's the
woman nunu is the man I'm sure I'm like
master like I wrote a story about them
becoming addicted to gambling and then
dying I was like that's what this book
is and it's it's jokes and [ __ ] in there
but he's like yeah sure it's just about
like it's about that real [ __ ]
even that is addiction so what's the
anytime all people about any time old
people discover an addiction late life
it's hilarious when they found them
slots I was like it's a [ __ ] wrap
Christmas was never to say what's the
editing process like though like if you
are writing while you're in a k-hole do
you then go back while you're sober and
like edit or do you just know these are
drug stories no they were it was [ __ ] so
I that's not that four times it's like
the same thing for time like take it out
take it out the raw emotion is good to
get down and the experience but then you
go back and you kind of [ __ ] fix it a
little bit
yeah like hyena the first the first
story I wrote while right after I
overdosed on pcp so it was like I was
high on PCP the firt you crack the book
and it's me on PCP telling you a story
that's great yeah that's great you're
hearing something no there's no way to
capture that if you're sober like the
only way to do it is to do it in the
moment to have a and you still will fix
it when you're sober make it a real
story but there's no way to capture that
[ __ ] feeling you know she don't do
PCP that I did PCP once because I
couldn't find ketamine they're in the
same food group and on that pyramid yeah
it was there both disassociative Zoar
some [ __ ] like that oh my god well PCP
is like ketamine miles we'll try that
yeah just somewhere enough for me to OD
on that [ __ ] when I was like 16 I was
and I hung out with kids that did a lot
of drugs I don't have many friends and
they were like they were like you know
nineteen twenty and I was like sixteen
and usually did they just smoke weed and
I I you know partake but this dude did
PCP and he just sat in the chair and I
was just looking out I thought he was
like I thought he was dead and then I
got up close to his face and he just
went dude I ran out and I went home I
was so scared and then they just made
fun of me for that forever